[Applause]
let's guess epic performances an
unexpected reunion City star-studded
50th birthday bash brought Kanye West
and jay-z back together again and looks
like everything is all good that you
have been feuding for several years
after clashing over business deals back
in 2017 J opened up about their
friendship to the New York Times
it's complicated relationship with us
Kanye came into this business on my
label so I've always been like his big
brother
and we're both entertainers it's always
been like a little underlying
competition there with your big brother
and we both love and respect each
other's art too so it's like a
we both everyone wants to be the
greatest in the world
Kanye also said he was hurt that jay-z
and Beyonce didn't attend this wedding
to kim kardashian in 2014 in a nearly
two hour-long interview with Charlamagne
tha God from I Heart Radio is the
Breakfast Club
I was heard about them not coming to the
wedding I understand they was going
through some things but if his family
you know you're not gonna miss a wedding
but nothing like a Hollywood party to
hash it out the two rappers attended
with their wives Beyonce and Kim
Kardashian all cream vivienne westwood
trust
buddy makeup everywhere and not a drop
on my clothes Khloe Kardashian and Kylie
Jenner were also there but it doesn't
end there
party bein husband off set post Malone
Kate Beckinsale Ellen Pompeo Kevin Hart
and Paris Hilton were all there to toast
Diddy and of course it wouldn't be a
proper celebration without a superstar
performance thanks to mary j blige
the birthday boy got down on the dance
floor
[Music]